-More sexual-assault allegations
have rocked Congress
and the news business,
as allegations surfaced
against some of the biggest
names in those industries.
Meanwhile, President Trump
broke his silence
on Alabama Senate candidate,
Roy Moore,
coming out in support
of an accused sexual predator.
For more on this,
it´s time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
For almost two weeks,
Trump has faced
repeated questions
about his position on Moore,
and for two weeks,
Trump has done everything he
could to avoid answering them.
For example, yesterday,
he ignored shouted questions
from reporters about Moore
and announced that
for the Thanksgiving holiday,
he had plans to get out of D.C.
altogether.
-I just want to wish everybody
a very, very happy Thanksgiving.
We´re gonna be working very hard
during the recess in Florida.
We´re going to Florida.
-Only Trump could get,
"We´re going to be
working very hard,"
and, "We´re going to Florida,"
in the same sentence.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe Trump thinks
he´s working hard
because Twitter went
from 140 characters to 280.
"My workload --"
[ Applause ]
"My workload has doubled."
[ Laughter ]
"Sometimes I have to type
´tax cuts´ and #MAGA
in the same tweet."
[ Laughter and applause ]
So now, for two weeks, since the
news about Moore first broke,
we´ve been waiting to find out
if Trump could summon
at least a shred of decency
and disavow a man
accused of preying
on teenaged girls,
and, today, we found out
that the old saying is true --
sexual predators of a feather
flock together.
-We don´t need a liberal person
in there, a Democrat.
Well, he denies it.
Look, he denies it.
I mean, if you look at
what is really going on
and you look at all the things
that have happened
over the last 48 hours,
he totally denies it.
He says it didn´t happen.
-And in fairness to Trump,
who are you gonna believe?
Nine women
who don´t know each other
and whose stories
have been corroborated
by dozens of independent sources
or a guy who looks like
the Marlboro Man´s deadbeat dad?
[ Laughter ]
But one --
[ Cheers and applause ]
"I got to run out
for cigarettes."
"But I am cigarettes!"
[ Laughter ]
But one of the most
revealing parts came
when Trump denounced
Moore´s Democratic rival,
Doug Jones,
a lifelong prosecutor,
who convicted the KKK members
responsible for
the Birmingham church bombing
that killed four little girls,
as soft on crime.
-Jones --
I´ve looked at his record.
It´s terrible on crime.
I could tell you for a fact,
we do not need somebody
that´s gonna be bad on crime.
But I can tell you,
you don´t need somebody
who´s soft on crime like Jones.
-He´s soft on crime?
You´re siding
with an accused child molester
over a guy
who prosecuted the KKK.
You´re so soft, you look like
a tub of melted playdough.
[ Laughter ]
And Trump, of course --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump, of course, is not alone.
He´s not alone in backing Moore,
who´s been accused
of sexual assault by nine women,
several of whom
were teenagers at the time.
Yesterday, White House counselor
Kellyanne Conway
urged Alabamans to vote for
Moore to help pass GOP tax cuts.
And an adviser to a pro-Trump
Super PAC, Katie Walsh,
a former White House official,
made a similar argument.
Listen as she tries
to have it both ways on Moore.
-So their position is literally
Roy Moore should step aside,
but if he doesn´t,
you should vote for him.
That´s gonna make their
pro-Moore TV ads very awkward.
-Who is Roy Moore?
The New York Times says
"Four more women have accused
Roy Moore of misconduct."
And The New Yorker reports
that "Moore was banned
from the Gadsden Mall."
And more than 20 Republicans
have called for Roy Moore
to step aside.
But if he doesn´t,
you should vote for him anyway
so we can give corporations
a giant tax cut!
Roy Moore --
he should step aside.
But if he doesn´t, you know,
make him a senator, okay?
Paid for by a group
of chicken [bleep] ass [bleep]
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Meanwhile...
Meanwhile, as Trump
sides with Roy Moore,
the avalanche
of sexual-assault allegations
that have consumed virtually
every aspect of society
from politics to entertainment
to media continued this week.
For example, yesterday,
we learned that eight women
told The Washington Post
longtime television host,
Charlie Rose, made unwanted
sexual advances towards them,
including lewd phone calls
and walking around naked
in their presence.
Good Lord.
Usually when someone that old
is walking around naked,
a couple of male nurses
lead him right back to his room.
[ Laughter ]
That´s right -- Charlie Rose
walked around naked.
It´s the only time
anyone´s ever said,
"Thank God there are no lights
on this set."
[ Laughter ]
Here´s a good rule of thumb.
If your face
isn´t pulling in the babes,
your penis isn´t gonna
make the difference.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Everybody´s penis is 100%
less attractive than their face.
Women don´t love the penis.
If they love the man,
they´ll tolerate the penis.
The best -- The best --
your penis can ever hope for is,
"Well...all right."
[ Laughter ]
This whole situation
is like a reverse "Bachelor."
Nobody wants
to accept this rose.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, the Post reported
that there were striking
commonalities
in how Rose
treated the women around him.
You know, I´ll just say it --
it might be time to retire
the bathrobe entirely.
It´s a terrible idea
for a garment.
Here´s a giant towel
that you tie together
with a skinnier towel.
And you never hear
a positive news story
involving a bathrobe.
It´s never "Family of four
pulled from burning house
by a man in bathrobe."
[ Laughter ]
It is always
"Some creep was creeping it up
in a creepy [bleep] bathrobe."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And Rose wasn´t the only
powerful man in media
accused of harassment yesterday.
There was also New York Times
White House correspondent
Glenn Thrush.
Yesterday, Vox published a piece
about Thrush´s history
of bad judgment
around young women journalists.
In that report,
the author described
how Thrush cornered her
at a bar by essentially
dismissing a female colleague
who was with them.
I´m sorry, but you don´t
get to call yourself a grown-up
if you dress like you´re wearing
a reporter Halloween costume.
[ Laughter ]
Another similarity in all
these stories is the degree
to which alleged abusers like
Thrush went to silence women.
They preyed on
and undermined their careers.
This culture
of bullying and intimidation
is toxic and pervasive,
and in Thrush´s case,
he reportedly sought
to portray the women
he victimized as aggressors.
Can you imagine
having the confidence
to say young women
came on to you
while you were also
wearing a fedora?
[ Laughter ]
And it wasn´t just the news
business that was rocked
by sexual-harassment
allegations yesterday.
Buzzfeed reported last night
that Michigan Congressman
John Conyers...
But you never heard the story,
because the former employee...
A temporary employee who shows
up but doesn´t do any work.
So basically, they made her
a member of Congress.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
So as a swirl of horrifying
sexual-harassment allegations
consumes virtually
every aspect of society,
President Trump
is publicly standing by
an accused sexual predator.
Nine women have accused
Roy Moore of sexual assault,
and Trump doesn´t seem to care.
I guess you could say Trump is,
uh, what´s the phrase?
-Soft on crime.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]